- You're engaged.
Congratulations.
- I am thank you.
- That's exciting.
This is my favorite thing
to learn about you though.
Her name is Taylor.
(giggles)
- [Taylor] It is, it is.
- [Kelly] What?
- [Taylor] We either.
- [Kelly] What were the chances?
- [Taylor] We either keep it super simple
or super complicated.
- Okay, do you go by
Taylor and she goes by Tay?
- Yes.
- Okay, that makes it easy.
- [Taylor] Or, a lot of people
just do boy Tay and girl Tay.
(kelly giggling)
- Oh my God, it sounds
like you're in morne story,
like pre-K.
- Yeah,
- Yeah, so either Taylor
and Tay or boy Tay girl Tay,
whatever works.
- How did y'all meet?
- Funny story.
My sister actually introduced us.
- Oh, I love that.
- Yeah, my sister always.
- Your family approved first that's nice.
- Yeah, it's just me and my sister,
so we're super close.
And she always said
that she was going to
introduce me to my future wife.
And I was like, sure.
- Oh my gosh.
- But she actually did, yeah.
- That's so cool.
- She was like, I have an idea,
throw,
because I love game nights.
She's like throw a game night,
invite me and some of my friends over,
I'll bring Tay.
She'll just be one of them,
and you guys can just meet.
- [Kelly] Feel it out.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] It worked out.
- We hit it off and the rest is history.
- She should start a company
of setting people up.
- Right? Yeah.
- So how did, how did
you end up proposing?
- You know, Tay is awesome,
and this is one of the
things I love about her.
She's like, I don't want anything special.
I don't want anything grand.
I just want to, like do it in the kitchen.
Like I love to cook.
So I make us dinner all the time.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And she's like one night
when we're just like having dinner
and a glass of wine,
like that's all I want.
So I did do it in the kitchen,
but I did it big in the kitchen.
I had it filled with flowers.
- [Kelly] We had this picture and I mean,
what are we talking about
with the flowers and the fire?
I love it.
- [Taylor] Yeah.
- [Kelly] And it's like,
I love that you have the neon sign like,
are you into this last name?
(both laughing)
- So you approve,
cause we already share one name.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It's going to be extra complicated.
- [Kelly] Oh my God, I actually
didn't think of that
(giggles)
- I know.
We're literally going
to be the same person.
- [Kelly] Oh my God, that's amazing.
- Its ridiculous.
- I just thought of that, oh.
- [Taylor] How narcissistic.
- It's amazing. It's great.
It'll be easier.
- [Taylor] Yeah, yeah.
- But, so she shared this photo.
From when I don't know,
she must have been like 10
years old and this is great,
because everyone's into Twilight.
Everybody loves Twilight.
I actually loved the books
before the first movie even came out.
- [Taylor] Oh wow.
- I thought it was good.
- Yeah
- It was, it was fun.
And then I loved the movies,
but here's what I wanna ask tho,
was she and Edward fan or a Jacob fan.
- That is the question.
- [Kelly] Was she a
- She was, she was team Edward.
(giggles)
- That's awesome.
- Yes, she was.
- That's amazing.
- But so she she's made up for it.
I'm allowing her to make that mistake.
It's in her past,
- [Kelly] Yeah, we all have past.
- So she's good now, but she,
she was not team Jacob unfortunate.
- That's so funny. I love it.
All right will,
- [Taylor] Still love her.
- Lets take a,
Its a good thing.